-Trois attaques, peut-être sept,
nous dit-on de source policière.
Au moins trois ont été perpétrées
à Paris et autour de Paris.
-On n'a jamais connu
un attentat comme ça
dans les rues de Paris.
On n'a jamais
été confrontés
à une action de guerre.
Musique sombre
...
Coups de feu
-C'est la guerre, avec l'odeur
de la poudre, du sang,
la vision.
C'est la guerre.
-On ne pense pas trop,
à ce moment-là.
On essaie surtout
de prendre les bonnes décisions.
-Déterminer qui a fait quoi,
comment, avec qui
et pourquoi.
-C'est une toile.
C'est tellement énorme.
Je pars de trois personnes
qui nous ont tiré dessus,
un an après,
on me parle d'une quantité de gens,
on me parle du financement,
des armes,
tout devient énorme.
-45 000 cotes,
45 000 pièces de procédure,
1740 parties civiles
et 350 avocats à ce jour.
Au moins 6 mois d'audience
dans une salle
de 600 places
spécialement construite au coeur
du palais de justice de Paris.
-C'est un procès
d'une très grande ampleur
et qui n'est comparable à rien.
-Ce procès,
on n'a pas le choix,
il doit être historique.
-Que n'a-t-on pas fait,
que n'a-t-on pas empêché,
comment ces attentats
ont-ils pu se produire ?
-La liberté aura le dernier mot.
Vous avez agi de manière effroyable,
vous allez être condamnés
de manière démocratique.
...
*-Le Stade de France,
le coup d'envoi dans un instant.
La finale aura lieu
le 10 juillet 2016,
du championnat d'Europe
des nations.
Vous découvrez les capitaines.
*Ambiance de stade
...
Tout devrait bien se passer
face à l'équipe de France.
C'est parti, avec un coup d'envoi
donné par les Allemands.
Musique de tension
...
Détonation
-La première détonation
fait surgir immédiatement
l'idée que nous pouvons avoir,
dans le stade,
une bombe qui explose.
Pendant quelques minutes,
nous pensons que ça reste un pétard
ou une bombe agricole
à l'extérieur du stade.
C'est au moment
de la deuxième détonation
que je n'ai plus de doute.
Je prends conscience
que nous sommes peut-être
devant une opération
beaucoup plus importante,
et qui n'est pas terminée.
Détonation
Je m'éclipse
à la 60e minute du match.
Avec Bernard Cazeneuve,
nous regagnons
très rapidement Paris.
Musique sombre
-Très vite, nous apprenons
qu'il y a des coups de feu
dans les rues de Paris
et qu'à ce moment-là, nous sommes
face à une attaque de masse.
-J'ai été emporté par l'effroi quand
j'ai su tout ce qui se produisait
sans que je puisse le voir
sur les terrasses
et au Bataclan.
*Ce que les terroristes veulent,
c'est nous faire peur,
nous saisir d'effroi.
Il y a effectivement
de quoi avoir peur,
il y a l'effroi.
Je me rends ensuite sur place,
au Bataclan.
Je vois des gens sortir du Bataclan.
Ils sont encore là,
blessés ou pas blessés,
comme des fantômes
qui sortent de ce lieu terrible.
-Le 13 novembre
est la soirée de ma vie
qui ressemble le plus à la mort.
La mort est partout.
Et c'est très étrange,
comme sentiment.
La mort vous cerne.
-On est dans des étiages
qui sont d'une violence inouïe.
130 morts,
700 blessés,
c'est indescriptible.
*-C'est une terrible épreuve qui,
une nouvelle fois,
nous assaille.
Nous savons d'où elle vient,
qui sont ces criminels,
ces terroristes.
-Nous vivons cet événement
avec le sentiment
que survient ce soir-là ce que
nous redoutions depuis longtemps.
-La question
n'était pas de savoir
si la France était exposée
à un risque majeur,
on savait bien qu'on avait un risque
d'une opération importante
qui risquait de venir
de l'extérieur,
la question était plutôt
de savoir où, quand et comment.
Musique sombre
...
-Le 13 novembre fait partie
de ma vie,
mais le 13 novembre
ne me définit pas.
Ca ne définit pas qui je suis.
Mais je ne peux pas renier
que ça fait partie de ma vie.
Est-ce j'ai fait des choses
que je n'aurais pas faites
sans le 13 novembre ?
Certainement.
J'ai un fonctionnement
un peu analytique,
j'aime bien savoir
qui fait quoi, pourquoi.
Ca m'intéresse de savoir
qui a voulu nous tuer.
Ca m'intéresse
de savoir pourquoi.
Et ça m'intéresse
de savoir comment.
L'idée de mes notes,
c'est essayer de comprendre
les donneurs d'ordre, l'origine,
comprendre
ce qu'était la structure
au sein de l'Etat islamique,
qui a commandité les attentats,
qui étaient les commandos,
comment ils étaient constitués.
Assez rapidement,
je me rends compte
que je vais avoir besoin
d'un avocat.
Je me dis qu'il va sans doute
y avoir un procès.
Même si je suis pas sûre
qu'on attrape quelqu'un,
j'ai besoin de savoir
ce qui se passe.
...
-En 2015, il va y avoir
tellement d'attentats,
tellement de besoins
et assez peu d'avocats
qui sont en mesure de répondre
à la fois à un flot de victimes,
aux problèmes d'indemnisations,
aux problèmes de pénal
en France et ailleurs,
je me retrouve l'avocat
de victimes d'attentats.
C'est petit à petit,
en travaillant les dossiers
et en essayent de faire des liens
entre les dossiers,
que je vais finir
par comprendre
que si ça arrive en France
à ce moment-là,
ça n'est pas, finalement,
par hasard,
et c'est le résultat
d'un plan ourdi et concerté.
Musique sombre
...
-Au mois de juin 2014,
le calife al-Baghdadi va proclamer
le califat, et ce qui n'était
qu'une organisation terroriste
devient un proto-Etat
à cheval sur deux pays,
la Syrie et l'Irak.
...
-Ils sont lancés dans une véritable
guerre pour occuper des territoires.
C'est la première fois
qu'une organisation terroriste
non seulement
commet des attentats,
agit contre un Etat,
en l'occurrence l'Irak,
mais occupe un territoire,
occupe une ville.
...
Détonation
-Dans le courant de l'été 2014,
une coalition internationale
va se mettre
à bombarder les territoires
tenus par l'Etat islamique.
Ca va occasionner
beaucoup de dégâts.
*Un homme parle dans son micro.
...
Explosions
Cris et pleurs
...
Cette organisation
se doit donc de réagir.
En septembre, le porte-parole
de l'Etat islamique
Abou Mohammed al-Adnani
déclare entre autres...
-Ce ne sont pas
des paroles verbales.
Ces individus
commettent des crimes
et des attaques
extrêmement meurtrières
en Irak et en Syrie.
Nous savons donc
que cette menace existe.
Est-ce qu'elle peut prendre la forme
d'attentats sur notre territoire ?
Nous ne pouvons pas
en être certains,
nous ne savons pas encore
quels les réseaux peuvent exister
en France, en Belgique
ou dans d'autres pays européens.
Musique sombre
...
-Au début,
on n'a pas su trop appréhender
ce qui se passait réellement
en Syrie.
Des commandos projetés,
on les redoute
mais on n'y croit pas.
Il faut être très clair.
Certes, l'Etat islamique
est déjà très implanté
en Syrie et en Irak,
mais on n'imagine pas véritablement
qu'il ait une capacité
de pouvoir projeter,
comme l'a fait al-Qaida
le 11 septembre chez les Américains,
un tel commando.
C'est à partir de Verviers,
qui se situe juste un peu après
les attentats de Charlie Hebdo,
que là, on s'aperçoit qu'il y a
quelque chose de différent.
C'est le premier exemple concret
de personnes qui viennent de Syrie
et qui ont envie
de commettre quelque chose
sur le territoire national.
Musique pesante
...
*-C'est un pays confronté,
comme la France,
à la menace terroriste :
la Belgique.
Plusieurs opérations
antiterroristes ont été menées
à Verviers, près de Liège,
et à Bruxelles.
Elles visent des groupes
de djihadistes
de retour de Syrie
qui préparaient
plusieurs attentats.
...
-Avec la séquence de Verviers,
on est confrontés
à un changement de modus operandi,
qui prend de vitesse
les services européens.
Ces gens qui partent là-bas
peuvent revenir
et ils peuvent être
très dangereux.
C'est le moment
un peu charnière.
...
-J'étais inspecteur principal
pendant 15 ans au groupe
d'intervention de la DSU,
l'unité spéciale de la police
fédérale en Belgique.
C'est l'équivalent
du GIGN en France.
...
Il y a deux endroits
cruciaux,
où il y a un nid
de terroristes présumés :
c'est à Bruxelles
et à Verviers.
...
A un certain moment,
les enquêteurs arrivent
à loger les terroristes,
les protagonistes,
à Verviers.
Il y a des moyens techniques
mis en oeuvre,
ça tourne 24/24h
pour voir
ce qu'ils font
et dans quel sens ils vont.
C'est des gens
qui ne sortent pas beaucoup,
ils ne sortent jamais à deux,
ils sont très structurés,
très bien organisés.
C'est le mois de janvier,
il fait sombre, froid, il pleut.
Ils mettent un bonnet
et on ne les voit pas.
Les identités, à ce moment-là,
on n'est pas sûrs à 100 %.
Dans les écoutes,
on se rend compte
que les gars préparent
vraiment quelque chose.
Ca incite le parquet
et la direction
de nouveau à passer
à une vitesse supérieure.
Le jeudi,
il y a toute une mise en place,
les snipers de chez nous
se mettent en place,
et il y a aussi les collègues
du GIGN qui s'y mettent.
-A un certain moment,
on ne peut plus attendre,
un troisième arrive
dans la planque.
On ne sait pas trop ce qu'il apporte
et on ne peut pas courir le risque
de laisser sortir ces gens-là,
donc on doit intervenir.
-Vers 16h15-16h30,
on a le go, le feu vert.
Et là, l'assaut est donné.
Coups de feu
...
Dans la seconde, on se ramasse
une rafale de kalachnikov.
On sent directement
qu'on est tombés sur des très durs.
Ils tirent, ils tirent.
Nous, on riposte
assez rapidement, aussi.
Au bout de 30 secondes,
le premier est éliminé.
Par contre, il reste le deuxième,
qui est entre
la partie avant et la partie arrière
de l'appartement, et lui,
c'est un dur à cuire,
il veut pas se laisser faire
et il veut mourir là,
c'est sûr.
Le sniper du GIGN
propulse une grenade
qui met le feu
à l'appartement.
Détonations
Mais le gars,
on sait pas très bien le situer.
En plus, il y a
une évacuation de fumée qui se fait
à l'avant et à l'arrière
du bâtiment.
Lui-même avance
dans cette boule de feu,
il avance,
et à un certain moment,
il est à quelques mètres
de notre équipe,
il est à 7-8 mètres
de mon équipe,
et là, on arrive
à finir la mission.
Quand tout se calme un peu,
après une minute,
tout à coup, il y a un des gars
à l'arrière, un des snipers,
qui voit une ombre
dans ce dégagement de fumée.
Et là, c'est le troisième,
qui venait de Bruxelles,
qui se rend, en fait.
L'enquête dira par après
que dans les 24 heures,
ils voulaient aller
faire un carnage
en uniformes de police,
qui ont été retrouvés
dans l'appartement
et se faire péter,
probablement,
avec une ceinture d'explosifs.
-Nous savons depuis Verviers
que nous sommes devant cette menace
non pas nouvelle,
car la menace n'a jamais cessé,
mais d'opérations
de beaucoup plus grande envergure.
La preuve, c'est que nous verrons
que les individus
qui étaient à Verviers
ou autour de Verviers, en Belgique,
on les retrouvera
dans ce qui s'est produit
au Stade de France,
sur les terrasses et au Bataclan.
-C'est le premier attentat
où apparaît Abaaoud.
Le nom d'Abaaoud apparaît
à ce moment-là.
Musique sombre
...
-Abdelhamid Abaaoud,
c'est un jeune Belge
qui a fait un peu de prison
pour de menus larcins,
qui certes vient
du quartier de Molenbeek
qui a tant défrayé la chronique,
mais qui était fils de commerçants,
donc issu de la classe moyenne
ou classe supérieure.
Quand il rejoint la Syrie,
il va montrer un appétit
pour les combats
et les exactions diverses
et variées qu'il va commettre,
mais par ailleurs,
il va se servir de l'argent paternel
pour financer des achats d'armes,
ce qui va le faire aussi
monter en grade.
...
-Abaaoud est dans les fichiers parce
qu'on sait qu'il est parti en Syrie,
on sait qu'il est revenu,
qu'il a enlevé son petit frère
et qu'il l'a amené
lui-même en Syrie.
...
-Je vous renvoie à la vidéo
dans laquelle il se met en scène
au volant d'un pick-up
en train de traîner des cadavres
dans la campagne syrienne.
Il parle en arabe.
...
-Des quads, des motocross...
-Il y a cette vidéo
qu'on va voir partout,
où il tracte
des corps de Syriens
qu'ils viennent de tuer
avec ses complices.
Ce volontarisme, si j'ose dire,
dans l'horreur,
va le faire monter en grade
au sein de l'Etat islamique.
-Sa promotion provient
de juillet 2014,
où il est nommé émir
au sein de la katiba al-Battar.
Il prend à ce moment-là plus
de 150 combattants sous ses ordres.
...
-Abaaoud, on le connaissait déjà.
Dans le cadre de ce dossier
qui nous amène à Verviers,
on apprend
qu'il pourrait être à un poste
où il tire un peu les ficelles
et où il organise les choses.
Donc, cette information,
nous l'avons partagée
avec l'ensemble de la communauté
policière européenne.
-Dans l'enquête, on nous dit
effectivement que les gars
sont dirigés par quelqu'un
qui est localisé en Surie
et/ou en Grèce.
A Athènes, plus précisément.
Musique sombre
...
-Les services finissent
par comprendre
qu'il est à Athènes.
La police grecque
va essayer d'arrêter Abaaoud.
Ils étaient aidés de la DGSE,
mais aussi des services américains
et vraisemblablement du Mossad.
Donc, on a déjà là
des moyens considérables
qui montrent que les services
ont pris la mesure
du danger qui couvait.
Mais malheureusement,
ça va échouer.
...
-Le 15 janvier,
quelques minutes après
le coup d'assaut contre Verviers,
les services grecs
font une sorte de coup de filet
dans un quartier
où le téléphone est géolocalisé,
mais le coup de filet
est très important
dans un quartier très fréquenté,
il y a énormément de monde.
-Abaaoud lâche son téléphone,
l'abandonne,
il est retrouvé
quelques jours plus tard,
et passe entre les mailles du filet.
...
-Ils ratent Abaaoud.
Apparemment,
ça se joue à quelques minutes,
à quelques dizaines de minutes,
mais ils le ratent
et il redisparaît
dans la nature.
...
-Quelques semaines après
paraît dans Dabiq,
un magazine de propagande
de l'Etat islamique,
une interview d'Abaaoud,
qui se moque
des forces de l'ordre européennes
en disant :
"Regardez,
je fais ce que je veux,
"je me déplace comme je veux
en Europe, c'est une passoire."
Il va se vanter d'avoir réussi
à se procurer des armes
et à planifier des opérations
contre les croisés.
Les services vont découvrir
dans une de ses planques à Athènes
un ordinateur.
Dans cet ordinateur, les expertises
vont permettre de découvrir
un projet d'attentat
qui vise l'aéroport
de Zaventem, en Belgique.
Musique sombre
...
-Dès janvier 2015,
avec ce coup de filet de Verviers,
Abaaoud apparaît comme quelqu'un
de prioritaire pour la DGSE.
-Cet individu, Abaaoud,
est repéré,
mais ce serait une faute
de penser qu'il est le seul,
puisque c'est une chaîne,
en réalité.
Il y a une hiérarchie
plus ou moins explicite,
il y a des chefs, des sous-chefs
et des relais qui se font.
-Cet attentat déjoué de Verviers
montre déjà un premier degré
de sophistication.
On a à Raqqa les cerveaux,
à Athènes le coordinateur
opérationnel Abaaoud
et en Belgique une cellule
de logistique et des tueurs.
C'est malheureusement
les prémices de ce qu'ils vont
être capables de faire
et de ce qu'ils vont réaliser
le 13 novembre 2015.
...
-Pour revenir à l'origine
des terroristes,
comment ils se sont rencontrés,
comment ils ont été formés,
il faut revenir à la structure
de l'Etat islamique.
Musique de tension
...
Coups de feu
Ce ne sont pas que des gens
en sandales dans le désert.
C'est une erreur de penser ça.
Ils ont des compétences
de renseignement
et d'organisation militaire.
...
-L'Etat islamique
va développer une police secrète,
qui s'appelle l'Amniyat.
En arabe, ça désigne le mot
"sécurité", ou "secret", aussi.
Et donc,
c'est le service secret
fondé par l'Etat islamique
pour tenir son territoire
à partir du moment
où il a eu un territoire à défendre.
...
-L'Amniyat est chaperonnée
par le porte-parole
de l'Etat islamique,
elle a un responsable :
Abou Lôqman.
Ils vont avoir, ce qui va nous
intéresser, une cellule spécifique
qui va être chargée
des opérations clandestines,
les OPEX,
opérations extérieures,
en dehors des Etats
contrôlés par l'Etat islamique.
...
-Un Franco-Algérien va être
très important dans l'histoire :
Abdelnasser Benyoucef,
qui est un ancien
des camps d'al-Qaida,
qui a été en Géorgie,
qui voulait
combattre en Tchétchénie,
qui est vraisemblablement
celui qui a eu l'idée de créer une
cellule des opérations extérieures.
-Benyoucef a vécu en France,
il a des origines
du côté de Villepinte, des Mureaux,
il a un réseau
et c'est lui qui est
le patron des attentats.
Un vieux routier.
-Aux côtés de Benyoucef,
on trouve son ami Samir Nouad,
qui est lui aussi algérien
et lui aussi un ancien du GIA.
-Et ensuite,
il y a les deux lieutenants
et amis très proches
de Benyoucef :
le Franco-Tunisien
Boubaker El Hakim,
qui avait été le premier Français
à rejoindre al-Qaida en Irak,
et le dernier, Oussama Atar,
un Belge,
qui lui aussi avait rejoint
les rangs d'al-Qaida
en Irak dans les années 2000,
qui aurait été en prison
avec al-Adnani
et même avec le futur calife.
Pour résumer,
il y a deux Algériens,
Abdelnasser Benyoucef,
Samir Nouad,
un Franco-Tunisien,
Boubaker El Hakim
et un Belge, Oussama Atar.
Ce sont ces quatre hommes
qui ont piloté tous les attentats
ayant frappé l'Europe
en 2015 et 2016.
-On va avoir des gens
qui sont très organisés,
qui ne se déplacent que cagoulés
et qui sont
des soldats extrêmement entraînés,
d'une sauvagerie, et c'est souvent
comme ça qu'ils sont recrutés,
sans limites,
et parmi ces personnes-là,
vous avez Abdelhamid Abaaoud.
Musique de tension
...
Abaaoud, c'est la cheville ouvrière,
c'est l'officier, et les autres sont
les officiers supérieurs.
C'est lui qui va recruter
à la fois des Belges et des Français
pour les renvoyer ensuite,
en les accompagnant s'il le faut,
sur le sol français et belge.
Musique pesante
-Après Verviers en janvier 2015,
l'Amniyat et sa branche OPEX
va tenter plusieurs opérations
principalement coordonnées
par Abaaoud, où il va projeter
des jeunes recrues,
qui ne sont pas
des vétérans du djihad,
très motivés,
à commettre des attentats
sur le sol français.
...
La deuxième après Verviers,
c'est l'attentat de Villejuif
commis par Sid Ahmed Ghlam
au mois d'avril 2015
au cours duquel
Aurélie Châtelain trouvera la mort.
...
-Sid Ahmed Ghlam,
un jeune homme qui vit en France,
rêve de mourir en martyr
depuis un certain temps.
Il va se rendre en Syrie,
il va rencontrer à ce moment-là
Abdelnasser Benyoucef,
Samir Nouad
et Abdelhamid Abaaoud.
Et on l'envoie
commettre un attentat
en région parisienne.
...
Benyoucef lui indique, lui propose
la gare de Villepinte.
Pourquoi Villepinte ?
Benyoucef vient de Villepinte,
il connaît la gare de Villepinte.
...
Ghlam, très discipliné,
c'est un étudiant, il est opiniâtre,
il bachote tout le temps,
il écrit tout ce qu'on lui dit,
il va faire le tour des cibles.
Il va aller à Villepinte,
il va regarder la gare,
prendre un film, mesurer le temps,
mais va être embêté parce qu'il y a
des caméras sur le parking,
donc il risque d'être pris,
et il y a quand même beaucoup,
beaucoup d'arabes.
C'est embêtant que ses victimes
soient musulmanes.
On va lui dire :
"Cherche d'autres cibles",
et c'est lui qui va proposer
comme cible une église.
*-Il s'appelle Sid Ahmed Ghlam,
est âgé de 24 ans et projetait
de commettre un attentat
contre ces deux églises catholiques
de Villejuif,
en banlieue parisienne.
Lorsqu'il a été interpelé,
l'attaque était imminente,
selon le ministre de l'Intérieur.
-Il a été plutôt bon
sur la phase repérage.
Les seuls éléments qu'on a de lui,
c'est quand il quittait
sa résidence universitaire.
Il y avait une caméra dans le hall.
En revanche,
il a été assez mauvais,
et c'est une constante
qu'on retrouve
sur beaucoup d'attentats,
dans la réalisation.
C'est-à-dire qu'il va assassiner
la malheureuse automobiliste
Aurélie Châtelain.
En revanche, semble-t-il,
en remettant son arme
dans son jean,
il a pas mis la sécurité
et il va se tirer une balle,
et c'est ce qui va mettre fin
à ce qui devait être
le véritable attentat
qu'il devait perpétrer,
c'est-à-dire une tuerie
dans une église.
*-Dimanche matin, à Paris,
dans le 13e arrondissement,
la police a découvert
dans le véhicule
et au domicile d'un individu
blessé par balle
un arsenal composé notamment
de plusieurs armes de guerre,
d'armes de poing,
de munitions,
de gilets pare-balles
et de matériel informatique
et de téléphonie.
-Ce qui est intéressant, aussi,
dans l'affaire
de l'attentat de Villejuif,
c'est ce que les policiers
vont trouver
dans le véhicule de Ghlam :
un classeur vert.
Dans ce classeur vert,
il y avait des dizaines
et des dizaines de pages manuscrites
sur ce qu'il fallait faire
et ne pas faire
avant l'attentat, pendant l'attentat
et après l'attentat.
Musique intrigante
...
-Sur Villejuif, nous voyons bien
que s'il a pu rater son opération,
ce qu'il avait en tête,
c'était d'aller dans l'église
et sans doute
de faire un massacre.
Donc, ce n'est pas
parce qu'une opération est ratée
qu'il n'y a pas derrière
un réseau.
Un réseau qui a manqué son objectif,
mais un réseau néanmoins
extrêmement dangereux
et sans doute assez ramifié.
-L'attentat raté, encore une fois
selon l'Etat islamique,
de Villejuif
va avoir des conséquences
sur la cellule des OPEX.
Abdelnasser Benyoucef,
le concepteur,
le fondateur de cette cellule,
a été vraisemblablement écarté
parce que certains s'étaient plaints
en interne
que ses apprentis terroristes
n'étaient pas assez formés,
qu'on les formait à la frontière
ou pas assez longuement.
Il va être mis sur la touche.
C'est ses deux amis et un peu
vraisemblablement lieutenants
Boubaker El Hakim et Oussama Atar
qui vont prendre sa place,
prendre du galon
et surtout,
mettre sur pied
un projet d'attentat
beaucoup plus ambitieux,
qui sera malheureusement
celui du 13 novembre.
Musique sombre
...
-Il y a trois francophones
qui ont été arrêtés
durant l'été 2015
et qui ont parlé
avec les services français.
Sirène de police
...
En premier,
il y a Nicolas Moreau,
qui a été expulsé et arrêté en 2015.
-Nicolas Moreau est un asiatique
qui a grandi
dans l'ouest de la France
et qui a combattu en Syrie.
Il a fait partie un peu
des forces spéciales
de l'Etat islamique.
...
Et cet homme,
quand il rentre,
au départ se tait
et un jour, pendant sa garde à vue,
va prendre la parole
et ne plus la lâcher.
...
Et il va confirmer des choses
que la DGSI pressentait,
il va leur parler de l'Amniyat,
il va mettre un nom
sur ce service de renseignement.
...
-C'est le premier à parler
de l'Amniyat en tant quel tel,
un des premiers à en parler.
Il explique qu'il y a cette cellule
des opérations extérieures,
le rôle d'Abaaoud
et d'Oussama Atar,
il commence à parler
de la route des migrants
et il explique qu'ils ont
des dizaines de volontaires
pour le djihad,
prêts à venir,
qui sont occidentaux et prêts
à venir mourir sur le sol français.
Le second, chronologiquement,
ça doit être Tyler Vilus.
Il tente de rejoindre l'Europe
au mois de juillet 2015,
il prend l'avion à Istanbul
avec un passeport suédois.
Sa photo n'est pas du tout
ressemblante.
La police de l'air
et des frontières turque
tique un peu et trouve
un interlocuteur qui parle suédois.
Forcément,
il ne sait pas répondre.
-C'est un Français
que la DGSI avait dans son viseur,
il s'appelle Tyler Vilus.
Il a fait partie de la police
de l'Etat islamique
et par ailleurs,
c'est l'homme
qui a pris sous sa coupe
un jeune Belge à son arrivée,
qui est Abdelhamid Abaaoud.
-Quand il vit à Shaddadi,
là où habitaient
les combattants français et belges,
il travaillait au sein
de la police islamique.
Dans la même ville vivaient
Mohamed Aghgad,
Mostefaï et Samy Amimour,
les trois membres
du commando du Bataclan.
-Il est placé
dans un centre de rétention,
il arrive à se procurer
ou à conserver son téléphone
et il va échanger avec Abaaoud.
Il lui dit : "T'inquiète pas,
dès que je sors, je tape."
Est-ce qu'il devait participer
à un attentat tout seul,
comme il le prétend ?
Ou, et c'est la grande question,
est-ce qu'il devait être
le 11e homme
du commando du 13 novembre ?
Et s'il l'avait été,
quel rôle il aurait joué ?
Je le rappelle,
c'est lui qui a formé Abaaoud,
et vu son parcours en Syrie,
on le voit mal avoir
un rôle de simple exécutant,
si j'ose dire.
-Le troisième à être arrêté
durant l'été 2015 et à parler
de la menace des attentats,
c'est Reda Hame.
Il va dire : "J'ai été clairement
mandaté par Abdelhamid Abaaoud,
"j'ai été formé
dans un centre spécial
"lié à préparer et commettre
des attentats en Europe."
Une formation aux armes,
aux explosifs,
une formation
à la communication cryptée.
Musique sombre
...
-Quand la DGSI lui demande
s'il est au courant
d'une possible attaque en France,
il explique qu'à l'heure actuelle,
à Raqqa, c'est l'usine à kamikazes.
"Ils arrivent."
...
-Il nous dit : "Il y a
une soixantaine d'opérationnels
"qui sont sur quatre pays",
mais c'est chercher une aiguille
dans une botte de foin.
Nous avons à ce moment-là
plus ou moins 5000 combattants
étrangers d'origine européenne
qui sont sur les lieux.
...
-Reda Hame donne
une indication supplémentaire,
une cible potentielle.
C'est exactement le programme
que vont appliquer
les trois terroristes,
les trois tueurs au Bataclan.
-On voit successivement,
à travers les différentes auditions
de revenants,
le rôle un peu plus précis
d'Abaaoud, en tout cas
le rôle plus central d'Abaaoud
et le risque que ça peut engendrer.
On ne sait pas où il est,
et c'est ça, le pire.
Il a été logé en Grèce
en janvier 2015,
et après, personne ne sait
où il est, il est dans la nature.
-On commence à chercher
dans tous les sens
et quand il se passe quelque chose
sur le Thalys, on n'est pas étonnés.
Musique de tension
...
-Le Thalys,
c'est une succession de miracles
si cet attentat est déjoué.
Un djihadiste, El Khazzani,
monte dans le Thalys à Bruxelles.
...
Il va aux toilettes
pour sortir de son sac ses armes.
Il a une kalachnikov.
Quand El Khazzani sort,
il y a quelqu'un
qui voulait aller aux toilettes
qui voit cet homme armé,
qui essaie de le retenir,
ça le ralentit.
Là, des militaires américains
ont compris que quelque chose
n'allait pas, il a déjà tiré
un premier coup de feu.
Autre coup de chance :
la kalachnikov,
qui est réputée ne jamais s'enrayer,
s'enraye.
...
Ce sont des images d'El Khazzani
quand il s'apprête à monter
dans le Thalys.
Vous le voyez, un jeune homme
avec ses petites lunettes de soleil,
sa valise. Le fait est qu'on ne peut
pas imaginer que cet homme a,
dans cette petite valise,
un arsenal qui devrait lui permettre
de tuer plusieurs centaines
de personnes
si son attentat avait réussi.
-S'il n'avait pas été
neutralisé par ces Américains,
et aussi par des Français,
car il faut aussi reconnaître
qu'il y a eu des voyageurs
extrêmement courageux,
cet individu aurait créé un carnage.
*-Saisi par les policiers,
un arsenal de guerre.
Fusil d'assaut kalachnikov,
pistolet automatique,
le terroriste
présumé avait de quoi tuer
des dizaines de personnes.
-On voit ce risque d'attaque
dans le train,
on voit ce risque d'attaque
d'un concert de rock,
on sait que c'est
dans les projets de l'EI.
On commence à avoir
quelques éléments,
mais on ne sait pas quand ni où
les choses vont intervenir.
Musique mélancolique
...
-Fin août, on a tout ce passif
et tout cette menace
qui est en train de monter.
Il est clair que les services
sont très inquiets,
le ministre de l'Intérieur
et le président de la République
sont au courant.
-Quand on interroge Patrick Calvar,
le patron de la DGSI, il dit :
"La dangerosité d'Abaaoud
dès l'été 2015,
"cet individu était impliqué
dans de nombreux projets avortés,
"Nous savions
qu'il avait joué un rôle
"dans plusieurs affaires,
dont l'affaire Ghlam,
"et nous l'avons signalé."
-Oui, il est identifié
déjà depuis plusieurs mois.
Après le Thalys,
on peut dire après Verviers aussi,
il est déjà dans notre zone
de surveillance.
Mais après, on peut savoir
que cet individu
joue un rôle important
dans le réseau,
mais où est l'individu en question ?
Musique sombre
...
*-Paris va peut-être changer
de stratégie
face au groupe Etat islamique.
La France devrait bientôt frapper
les djihadistes en Syrie,
c'est ce qu'indiquent
nos confrères du Monde.
*-La question a été abordée hier
lors d'un conseil restreint
de défense à l'Elysée.
L'entourage du chef de l'Etat
ne confirme rien.
-Le 4 septembre 2015,
à l'issue d'un conseil de défense
en présence du président
François Hollande,
la DGSE va faire
un message interne.
-Les services de renseignement
nous communiquent
des informations parcellaires,
mais qui convergent pour indiquer
la dangerosité de l'individu
et qui convergent pour dire
que nous devons procéder
à sa neutralisation.
*-J'ai demandé au ministre
de la Défense
que dès demain
puissent être menés
des vols de reconnaissance
au-dessus de la Syrie.
Ils permettront d'envisager
des frappes contre Daech
en préservant notre autonomie
de décision et d'action.
Musique de tension
...
*-La France a frappé en Syrie
cette nuit.
La France a frappé Daech en Syrie
cette nuit, à Raqqa.
Nous avons frappé
parce que nous savons
qu'il y a en Syrie,
en particulier
dans les environs de Raqqa,
des centres d'entraînement
de combattants étrangers,
dont la mission n'est pas d'aller
combattre pour Daech sur le Levant
mais de venir en France, en Europe
pour commettre des attentats.
-C'est une action qui est globale.
Nous ne réagissons pas simplement
parce que nous aurions
des terroristes identifiés
sur tel ou tel lieu.
Ca a pu arriver plus tard,
mais dans la décision que je prends,
c'est une décision stratégique.
Nous savons qu'il y a,
à Raqqa notamment,
des immeubles qui servent,
justement,
à accueillir un certain nombre
de personnes
qui nous veulent
directement du mal.
*-Vous êtes sûr qu'il y a eu
des victimes djihadistes,
que vous avez tiré la nuit...
*-Je ne commente jamais
nulle part
les résultats des frappes
que nous effectuons,
mais l'objectif a été atteint.
-Ces frappes de l'automne 2015
ciblent des djihadistes
supposés préparés à des attentats
visant la France.
Le nom d'un djihadiste français
va être révélé
par le journal Le Monde,
mais en fait,
il y avait une autre cible,
dont le nom
a été soigneusement tu,
c'était Abdelhamid Abaaoud,
qui était la vraie priorité
des services.
Ils n'ont pas compris,
à cette époque,
qu'Abaaoud avait quitté la Syrie
pour rejoindre l'Europe.
A telle enseigne
que le 3 novembre 2015,
donc 10 jours avant les attentats,
la DGSE écrit...
On est quand même très loin
d'Abdelhamid Abaaoud,
qui à cette heure-là se trouve
dans les environs de Bruxelles.
-Alors que les enquêteurs pensent
qu'Abdelhamid Abaaoud est en Syrie,
c'est une cible,
c'est un danger pour l'Europe,
et que le renseignement
essaie de mettre ses taupes,
le paquet, en Syrie,
à ce moment-là,
Abdelhamid Abaaoud est remonté
et il se cache à Bruxelles.
Musique sombre
...
Abaaoud a décidé,
vu comment s'étaient passées
les précédentes attaques,
de se présenter lui-même et
de venir lui-même
préparer la prochaine vague
d'attaques.
Il quitte la Syrie,
il passe par la Turquie,
il passe par la route des migrants,
il arrive en Grèce,
et avec l'auteur du Thalys,
il passe certainement
par un centre de migrants
où ses papiers passent à travers,
y a pas de photo,
y a des ratés à ce moment-là,
il remonte par la route des Balkans,
on sait qu'ils sont le 1er août
en Hongrie.
-Il est rentré en Europe
avec El Khazzani,
le futur terroriste du Thalys,
et il avait envoyé en éclaireur
un jeune qui prenait
la route des migrants
et ils échangeaient ensemble,
en disant :
"Cette route-là, c'est sûr.
"Là, en Hongrie, il faut faire ci
ou il faut faire ça..."
Et voilà,
il lui ouvrait la voie
pour être à chaque fois
dans des conditions
de sécurité maximum.
-On arrêtait Abaaoud.
Même si c'est pas le grand chef,
c'est celui qui bouge,
celui qui encadre
et celui qu'on pouvait attraper.
Les dysfonctionnements,
il est fort possible qu'il y en ait.
Et le procès devra être le lieu
où ces questions seront posées.
Musique de tension
...
-Abaaoud va se retrouver
dans un appartement avec El Khazzani
et son jeune éclaireur,
qui devait vraisemblablement
participer à l'attentat du Thalys,
et à partir de ce moment-là,
il y a un trou,
on n'a pas su
reconstituer
l'itinéraire d'Abaaoud
entre courant août
et les derniers jours
qui précèdent le 13 novembre.
...
-A ce moment-là, c'est un grand
désordre en Syrie, épouvantable.
L'ouverture des routes
pour les migrants
va être mise à profit
par l'Etat islamique,
qui se dit :
"C'est ça, notre solution.
"On va suivre
les chemins des migrants,
"donc on n'a plus
de problèmes de papiers,
"on n'a plus besoin de gens
"qui ont des passeports européens,
"on pourra avoir
des passeports syriens,
"et on va envoyer
"plusieurs dizaines de personnes
vers la France."
*-C'est la même scène qui se répète
inlassablement.
Des centaines de réfugiés,
éprouvés par des semaines
de voyage,
foulent le sol européen
pour la première fois.
-Après Villejuif, après Reda Hame
qui se fait arrêter,
après Verviers
et après le Thalys,
là, il y a une volonté très claire
de l'Etat islamique
de faire monter d'un niveau
les compétences des troupes.
-On envoie des guerriers
chevronnés et aguerris,
qui ont tous un passé militaire
au sein de l'Etat islamique.
Et comme on a envoyé
plein de gens,
on va pouvoir organiser un attentat
avec beaucoup de monde
et une véritable organisation
en commando.
-C'est de loin la menace
la plus structurée,
avec les gens les plus aguerris,
à laquelle on a eu affaire.
C'étaient des hommes d'action
qui étaient aussi soutenus.
Ils étaient soutenus
par des secteurs
de la criminalité organisée :
trafic d'armes, faux papiers,
ce genre de choses.
-Pendant cet automne 2015,
il y a des individus qui,
avec des faux passeports,
parviennent, à partir de la Grèce,
à rentrer dans l'Union Européenne.
Leur cheminement a été reconstitué
par l'enquête.
Ils séjournent en Belgique
assez longtemps,
dans les quartiers de Molenbeek,
et n'arrivent pour l'attentat
de novembre 2015
qu'à la dernière minute.
Musique sombre
...
-Le 12 novembre,
il y a différents groupes
parmi les attaquants du 13 novembre
qui se forment et qui partent
avec trois voitures différentes
pour Paris.
Il y a un premier groupe
dans une Polo,
qu'on appelle
"le groupe des Français".
Il semble assez clair
depuis le début
que c'est eux qui vont attaquer
le Bataclan, ils le savent.
Ensuite, il y a une Clio,
dans laquelle se trouvent
les frères Abdeslam
et leur ami Abrini.
E sont les Belges, qui sont amis,
qui se connaissent bien.
Et il y a une dernière voiture,
la Seat, dans laquelle se trouvent
le coordinateur, Abdelhamid Abaaoud,
Chakib Akrouh
et également
deux terroristes Irakiens,
qui se feront sauter
au Stade de France.
...
-Ma fille va venir,
elle va déjeuner.
Je me souviens, quand je lui dis
"vendredi 13", elle fait comme ça.
Et ce geste comme ça,
je dis à Jean-François :
"qu'est-ce qu'elle m'a dit ?"
Elle voulait dire :
"Je n'aime pas."
...
-C'était une belle journée,
il faisait doux,
c'était la fin de semaine,
on était contents d'aller au concert
et on s'est retrouvés dans la soirée
juste à côté du Bataclan
avec l'idée de passer
une bonne soirée ensemble.
...
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA